Harley Quinn might still be relatively new
to DC Comics, but she's already gone through
some significant style shifts in the years
since her debut.
What moviegoers got to see of that character
in Suicide Squad was just a sliver of her
story.
Here's a run-down of the most significant
moments in Harley's evolution.
Batman: The Animated Series
In 1992, Harley Quinn made her debut as the
Joker's right-hand gal in Batman: The Animated
Series.
The character was inspired by a surreal harlequin
scene from Days of Our Lives, featuring actress
Arleen Sorkin, an old friend of writer and
producer Paul Dini.
When Dini saw the scene, he knew exactly who
he wanted as the Joker’s new sidekick.
He recruited Sorkin herself to do the character's
voice.
"But what about all our friends?
Ivy and Two Face and Hat Guy and Lizard Man
and Puppet Head and-"
Her original ensemble was designed by artist
Bruce Timm, and remains her most iconic costume.
Early Appearances
Harley made her comic book debut in Batman
Adventures #12, maintaining much of the same
look as her animated appearance.
As the details of her seduction by The Joker
became a focal point, specifically in Batman
Adventures: Mad Love, she started to show
a little more shape and a little more sass.
In December 2000, she got her first comic
series, where she temporarily drops her relationship
with the Joker, choosing Poison Ivy instead.
The new series made her more realistic, but
it still kept her costume the same for its
full run.
Arkham Asylum
Harley's sex appeal made its first real appearance
in the 2009 video game Batman: Arkham Asylum,
making her barely recognizable.
Her backstory remained similar, but her look
was sharply different: blonde pigtails, a
revealing corset, and thigh-high boots.
She was also not as light-hearted as she'd
once been.
Dini, who also wrote the game, defends her
controversial changes, saying, "I wanted to
make it clear that Harley Quinn was out of
her mind."
"Surprise!"
"Ya know bats I always thought there was spark
between us."
This new version of Harley would also appear
in the rest of the Arkham series, each time
appearing slightly different.
The New 52
When DC rebooted the Suicide Squad comics
as part of its New 52 event, Harley got a
major style overhaul, introducing her red
and blue pigtails, corset, hot pants, and
heels.
The series also revamped her origin story
to include the chemical skin alterations later
seen in the cinematic version.
Soon after that, her standalone series got
its own reboot, and ushered in the era of
blue and pink eyeshadow.
Although the colors of her costume and hair
harkened back to her signature red-and-black,
her midriff, legs, and more were still on
full display.
Suicide Squad
The cinematic Suicide Squad followed suit
in displaying Harley's allure onscreen.
In the flick, Margot Robbie's Harley also
sported pigtails partially dyed blue and pink,
tiny shorts, a tattered t-shirt, red varsity
jacket, a ton of tattoos, and boots.
While the get-up paid tribute to the past
versions of the character, it also arrived
as its own new spin.
Bruce Timm, Harley’s original designer,
told Gizmodo that the character's new design
looked “really cool."
Dini, meanwhile, thought the Daddy's Monster
approach was a good way to make it work.
"I know it's jarring for a lot of the people
who love the classic Bruce Tim suit, I love
it myself, I mean if in that world, I just
don't see it happening."
The changes have since been incorporated into
DC’s Rebirth initiative, launched in the
summer of 2016.
This new Harley Quinn has the screen version's
hairstyle, makeup, and a much more urbanized
garment game.
Phew!
Keeping up with all those style changes can
be, well...vexing.
"I'm known to be quite vexing, I'm just forewarning
you."
Thanks for watching!
Subscribe to our YouTube channel to watch
more videos like the one you just saw.
And leave us a comment to let us know which
is your favorite Harley Quinn costume…